ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dylan show we are here in arizona don't
worry about it tour is over very soon
and then we are back in the studio
i've had enough uh it's been very fun
uh going out and doing stand-up comedy
again you begin to realize how much you
love it
uh and how much it is also uh destroying
your life
so it is nice to be out uh come
mid-november we're shutting it down
till the spring and then we'll do
another month in the spring um
but this will not this this constant you
know
airbnbs and rental cars and planes is
like that this was great not doing this
was phenomenal
and uh we'll i'm gonna get back to that
shortly i'm just gonna have a pandemic
no matter what
in my head i don't care if everybody
gets vaccinated i don't give a [ __ ] i'm
going back home locking the door
going back inside i will i'm not so when
i put out dates if you want to come see
me cool if not
don't but then it's going to be three or
four months of doing nothing
this this [ __ ] what i was going to do
last year is be on the road 40 weeks or
something crazy like that
i will never do that again um i am happy
doing these months month and a half
intensive tours and then [ __ ] being
done with it
uh because you know enough's enough i
can reach more people like this
to be honest than i can you know
comedy club by comedy club you know and
they're all lovely environments these
comedy clubs they're all
great you know i have owners of clubs
coming in and giving me uh you know
re-gifted ear pods as a gift for selling
it out
i appreciate it um but i will i will uh
i'll pass on that um
but it's been a lot of fun the shows are
really really fun
none of the problems that i have ever
have to do with the shows
which are the most fun it is every other
minute and hour of the day
getting to that stage that is taxing
um so you know
we're out when we're out we're out come
see us we have a lot of fun and then
when we're in we're
in and that is that is what i've learned
about this pandemic is that
it re-prioritized a lot of things for me
i'm going to put a lot more into digital
we're putting a lot into digital already
that's the future
the future is not i see all these comics
and i love them and i respect them
you know they're performing in fields
and on rooftops and wherever they can
and i get it
and i respect the hell out of that that
is not the future
that is over and i don't know what to
tell you
it's not maybe you don't like that
that's over many people don't
like many things um doesn't matter
the future is the future um we're here
in arizona
which is the worst state in the union uh
by far
there is no comparison there is nothing
worse than arizona
uh arizona is uh it is an
absolute i mean it has no redeeming
qualities
it is a hot arid desert landscape
with some of the trashiest least
intelligent human beings
uh to have ever uh you know
graced the [ __ ] you know
planet here it is bad there are some hot
people
there's some probably big only fans
accounts there's some aspiring porn
stars
there's a few guys it's probably fun to
get no ponzi scheme within scottsdale
there's a few people that own houseboats
on lake havasu that it's probably fun
it's a great place to be when you're 23
and you're trying to [ __ ] or whatever i
don't know but i mean get me out of here
get me out of here i've had fun the
shows are fun the crowds are fun
um but the crowds always they also feel
like it's like
you know in in you gotta if you lose
them for a minute you know god only
knows what happens
here god only knows what people are just
screaming
people are yelling and screaming um it
is it is a
it is truly an embarrassment the state
of arizona there's just no other way to
put it you know the owner of the club
was like
i'm staying in this place peoria the
owner of the club's like oh you're
staying in peoria what are you doing i'm
like buddy
the whole [ __ ] state should be
firebombed what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
you think you have an estate in the
pacific palisades it's a [ __ ] you're on
the surface of mars here
and everybody's a [ __ ] so what does it
[ __ ] matter
where i am the whole place is [ __ ]
it's irredeemable one of your best
restaurants in phoenix
has fried bread it's called the fry
bread house
and they take refried beans and put it
on fried bread
it's disgust i've really had it with the
west
i really have the country shot i drove
from utah
to [ __ ] arizona i'm sick of the red
clay canyons
and uh the general store i'm sick of
that hokey horse [ __ ]
frontier town crap it's enough already
grow the [ __ ] up
i'm sick of it give it back to the
indians
give it back to them the native
americans my apologies
but the country's shot it's disgusting
the grand canyon we passed that
looks the same as it did when i was a
kid it's disgusting
do something else
it's just enough already with these and
of course i'm with this 24 year old
who's opening for me who's i love but
he's an idiot so i mean he's like guys
isn't it beautiful isn't it beautiful
isn't it not you stop it's not nice
and it's not beautiful civilization is
beautiful
people working is beautiful not rock
formations
get out of the national parks please
you know it's beautiful uh families
progress that's beautiful
not a red clay rock formation
that looks like somewhere aliens land
and face [ __ ] you
oh zion national park is so beautiful
yeah it's great can you get me to
arizona please
so i could perform for these fry bread
heads it's like get the [ __ ] out of here
jesus christ these [ __ ] tan leathery
people
spent their entire life just [ __ ]
marinating themselves in vodka
i mean i appreciate arizona they're open
they're letting shows happen i'm down
with that man
they're letting things happen we're all
taking a few risks
these [ __ ] do not care they are
out there maskless
just [ __ ] partying
what are you gonna do we gotta live we
gotta do things
some people don't wanna live
that's the other thing i mean we're all
creating government policy based on the
idea that everybody wants to be here
that isn't true a lot of people's
actions suggest
otherwise so let them
uh infections are now up in new york
city
they tried what have they tried to do
they tried to shut down the uh hasidic
jews
yes because the hasidic jews aren't
having it in new york
they're not having it and listen
they're doing what they want to do so
meatball
and de blasio who are destroying the
city and state respectively
are now picking on the jews because
nothing else is going right
because the economy can't reopen because
they've destroyed the entire city
so now they're picking on the hasidic
jews they really don't bother anybody
they just
they walk around with big hats and some
of those hats are furry and i like those
hats and i don't know what they call
them
i always wanted to wear one you know
without
you know culturally appropriating or
being a victim of a hate crime
what is that hat called it's called the
strymel or shabbat hat
yeah you don't know what you're talking
about there's another type of hat that's
furry it's like a big furry hat
this one right by the way i watched that
documentary about hasidic jews one of us
and it was supposed to be
groundbreaking and it was just the same
they're like during a divorce
uh there's a oh the war of the fan i'm
like it's the same [ __ ]
can we stop pretending that everything's
so [ __ ] different please
the acidic jews are the same as these
people that want to get drunk on like
half suit they just don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care if they're gonna go
they're gonna go
stop trying to keep everyone on earth
for what
i mean this country is going to hell and
everybody wants to keep everyone here no
there are no jobs and everybody goes we
need more people to not do the jobs that
don't exist right
god forbid anyone die
god forbid the employment the
unemployment office line's a little
shorter if you take away people's
freedom
and you make them live in a [ __ ] uh
prison of of apps and
algorithms they are going to rebel
because that is not a life
that is not a life they want to be free
trump is running as tyrovera who's
opening for me very funny comic said
trump is running with freedom biden is
running with
maybe more lockdowns maybe more it's
probably going to be neck and neck
but i will say this if you're running as
a candidate of making decisions and
being free
you're pro you might win in this country
because we are deeply uncomfortable
people like me are deeply uncomfortable
with just having a federal government
uh stop us from working
indefinitely for for something where
there may not be a vaccine
this may be the best we do we may have
to let herd immunity build up
there isn't another option the economy
cannot be
decimated completely to protect
a small amount of people doesn't mean
the covet isn't real
or that it isn't serious or that there
aren't lasting effects
all of that is true and it is tragic
the tragedy in this country is is it's
all tragic by the way you know what
about the people
remember pre covert all the people that
didn't get health care and dropped dead
was that not tragic what about the
soldiers who got back from iraq who
didn't have mental health care and they
blow their brains out
a staggering amount of them every month
was that not tragic
is this the only [ __ ] thing that's
tragic by the way is coronavirus
is there anything else that [ __ ]
upsets you people how about the kids
that go to bed hungry every night is
that tragic
how about all the people whose jobs were
shipped to bangladesh and they were told
to rot in towns and do opioids with
their kids
is that [ __ ] tragic or is there no
[ __ ] tragedy that doesn't begin and
end with a [ __ ] cough
okay let's rein it in here
act like a [ __ ] adult everything's
tragic
life is suffering in hell not for me at
the moment i'm in a nice airbnb but it
ain't great
i don't like the design scheme it's
[ __ ] arizona it's the best we're
gonna do
i'm not complaining i'm just saying
this this attitude now that this is the
only problem we've ever fit nobody ever
died before this
god forbid i'm not saying you shouldn't
protect yourself if you're
immunocompromised or if you don't want
the risk you don't have to buy a ticket
to one of my shows i think you should
buy it and not come
nothing would make me happier nothing
would make me happier
than to sell out these shows and have no
one come
and walk out onto the stage and say my
fans are responsible then go back
to the airbnb so please if you are
responsible
buy tickets for chicago and denver and
kansas city and oklahoma city and do not
come
none of you come just shell out the
venues let me walk in
let me sit on the stage i'll feel safe
you all feel safe
and then i'll do an instagram live from
the airbnb it's a win-win
i come i get to check i never need to
work
i don't need to work and i think people
who do are very sick
i need to earn money i get that i don't
need to work for it
yelp is now yelp
so this is where we're at we have police
brutality we have a
very bad situation with the brianna
taylor with the no
knock warrant which is uh one of the
stupidest things that i've ever read
about
have known about the idea that the
government
can enter your house without knocking in
the middle of the night
to me is [ __ ] insane we have that
we have uh derek chauvin um
stepping on a man's neck for nine
minutes almost
killing him we have protests erupt all
over the country
we have instances of police brutality on
film and on camera
police need to be retrained they need to
be demilitarized
they need to reestablish um you know
a trust with with communities there
needs to be more community policing
there needs to be more stuff to fight
poverty in those communities
so that people aren't necessarily uh
given no other option but to uh you know
embrace a life of crime we need to
fight that battle on all fronts now
we're not doing any of that
but yelp
yelp has stepped in and is now allowing
fat americans to to
identify which restaurants are racist
because like everything else in america
uh the solution involves food and
dining there's nothing in america that
doesn't involve food
remember when the proud boys in the tv
were fighting they were throwing
milkshakes
they were throwing milkshakes at you it
was a dessert themed revolution here and
now to correct
police brutality to correct we now have
yelp stepping up and going hey let's
identify
uh which del taco
has a nazi working there or whatever i
mean i don't know
just some guy that hands you a taco and
looks you goes
you know the food's okay but these
people gotta go you're like god damn it
what is this yelp can you fill us in on
this because this is fascinating to me
can't i say any restaurant is racist if
i don't like it it looks like
like so and i will do that i have a list
of restaurants right now that i think
are
they are i will say that they're racist
yeah they'll add a racist behavior alert
to a business page when it has evidence
of
racist actions from a business owner
employee and they do that to podcasts
you better not do it to podcast i'll
tell you that much to determine if an
alert is warranted yep said it will rely
on and link to what it calls independent
news reports of alleged racist actions
associated with a business so yeah i
mean if you got a couple your friends
together
and you kind of got the same story it
looks like you could you know
and we could just say that for example
me and dan were driving
through uh utah we stayed at the best
western
bryce canyon fine you know we leave that
we drive we end
up somewhere uh a restaurant and uh
we have two steaks the guy told me he's
like you should get the bison i said you
should get out of here
so we have two steaks they're overcooked
whatever
what are you gonna do we're sitting
there
i mean the restaurant is it takes a long
time
food's not good what is to stop me
from saying that when the waitress put
the stake down on my table
she looked at me and she whispered heil
hitler
and then walked away what is to stop me
from doing that
nothing what is to stop me from doing
that
you know i don't understand
what would potentially if i could get a
few friends and we all had the same
story
and we could just say hey this
restaurant what do they mean
a ra what is it a racist activity alert
so this is what pops up when you pull up
the business business accused of racist
behavior with a big red exclamation
point and it has a disclaimer before you
visit the restaurant's page on yelp
dude no one's gonna care if it's a good
restaurant
if the food is good nobody's gonna give
a [ __ ]
it's also like the restaurants that are
really racist are poor restaurants
where usually minorities hate each other
can we can we go to a korean bodega that
hates black people it's a
racist behavior alert can we do that
i've been sitting in chinese restaurants
in new york where a black lady came in
and literally the chinese one goes
you'll pay now
like what is this here yeah is are we
gonna be able to just label everybody uh
every restaurant is racist racist
behavior alert
i witnessed racist behavior at this
restaurant
[ __ ] yelp [ __ ] you if you need yelp to
make a decision
[ __ ] you if you use yelp [ __ ] you if you
write reviews on you
[ __ ] all of that [ __ ]
it is grotesque i stayed in a horrible
airbnb
the dude was coked out of his gills he
kept coming downstairs to use the
[ __ ]
washer dryer he [ __ ] his kid tried to
open the door
the [ __ ] his roommate was walking
around at 2 3 a.m i'm like i don't even
think they were gay i think they were
just coke freaks
middle-aged guy with a roommate you know
what if you're not [ __ ] what bonds
you together
the love of the night so he's out there
at 2 a.m just stomping around and i like
me and dan go hey
you know because i'm up giving dan a
lecture about you know how superior i am
to him in comedy
and then go some guy just walked by it
through the yard
and i go what the [ __ ] so i call the
owner i go like can you tell me what's
going on here goes he's just taking out
the garbage at [ __ ] 2 a.m that's my
roommate
let me tell you right now the guy then
the guy starts asking me for tickets to
the show i'm like it's sold out he's
like there's nothing you can do
[ __ ] i don't know you you're doing
laundry in
the place i'm paying to stay you're not
watching your daughter who's trying to
get in the room and your coked out
roommate
is walking around the backyard at 2am
like he's about to do a home invasion
no there's nothing i can do i don't
review him negatively i refuse to review
him i'm not a rat
i'm not a rat i just don't review
my mistake my fault i don't review i say
i either review the airbnb's very well
or i don't review them at all that's it
that's
the game that i play i don't want to
destroy that guy's business
now should it be destroyed
unquestionably i mean the house was a
construction
site everything was a problem the
parking everything there was large
cinderblocks everywhere
he had different people in the yard
you could have easily justified writing
the worst review
ever but i did not do it because i'm not
a rat i do not feel comfortable
uh destroying somebody's ability to earn
money maybe the next person will like
that
maybe his next guest is all coked up and
likes strange people and children
wandering in the house and
maybe that's part of the fun maybe that
makes their vacation better
but not me but i don't review it i just
step back
i go let this [ __ ] do what he
wants to do you know
fine doesn't matter to me maybe he
reviews me maybe he does maybe he
doesn't i don't know
but i'm glad that yelp is now
solving the problem of racism so you can
go identify
uh if the if the waitress at applebee's
was right and by the way aren't these
major corporations gonna start to sue
yelp
for this oh interesting wouldn't
wouldn't you sue
yelp yeah maybe so yeah it's saying
i mean you might have to link to a news
article from a credible media outlet but
i mean
good luck finding one of them a credible
media outlet this is what
like i don't know what are we doing here
folks
just eat your food and move on you fat
[ __ ]
jesus christ
green cactus is transphobic just eat the
taco
i mean for the love of god this
is really just creeping into every
[ __ ] area it's
boredom this is boredom people are
bored and they and they don't know what
to do
and people at yelp are like how do we
capitalize
on all of the anti-racism that's
floating around
let's let people rat out restaurants
they feel are
racist
you should open a restaurant with the
best food
at the best deals and make it like
genuinely the most offensive restaurant
ever
like it should be an oppression themed
restaurant
swear to god the table should be little
gas chambers
and the people that serve you should be
ss guards and all the performers should
be slaves
slaves and then to the side of the
restaurant like the people that check
you in are irish
and they haven't eaten because of the
potato famine and they all look [ __ ]
inbred
and there should be them and then there
should be a back
garden of the restaurant called the gaza
strip
where you you don't even get food they
just throw
the the leftover food they found on the
floor they throw it at you
and if you try to get water they hit you
with a stick
and if you price that restaurant up
fairly
if you price that fairly people will go
if the food is good and it is priced
fairly i will straight up look at ben
ago we're going to nazi slaves tonight
we're going to nazi slaves you know i
like the buffalo chicken wrap because
it's nice to use the chunky blue cheese
we're going to nazi slaves so i don't
care if it makes you feel uncomfortable
and we're eating in the back garden of
gaza strip because of cover 19.
that's what they should [ __ ] do i
mean if i was a billionaire i would just
open the most
offensive restaurant known to man
and see what yelp did with that how do
you like this yelp
christ on the cross would greet you and
say hello
welcome to the restaurant and then you
know what you would do you would pin
a nail in christ's hand
and we'd have a burger a really big
burger and if you ate the burger
you would get to assassinate jfk like
we'd have a fake jfk and you could shoot
him
and then he'd splatter and then one of
the waitresses pretends to be jackie
and we put you on the wall and you said
you finished the jfk burger and
i killed kennedy and you'd have a big
smile on your face
the desserts would be 911 themed the
most
offensive restaurant known to man just
to [ __ ] with yelp
see what happens
i mean just just crazy bad
just crazy bad we would hand out
crayons and and and and pieces of paper
to the kids
but only if they drew mohammed
do you understand this restaurant would
last maybe a month in a mature
country this would be a hilarious
restaurant in a mature
country this would be hilaire
if we were a mature country
you should be able to go out and eat a
meal
in a restaurant that makes fun of
genocide
in a fun way now i guess i understand
the argument against this type of
restaurant too
i'm not i don't i'm not saying that i
don't understand that
but i'm just saying it's something to
hey it's something to consider
out there i like watches i don't really
wear them but
i i like them and i should be wearing
them more
ben has a beautiful watch and i asked
him the other day i said what watch is
this
and what did you tell me it's vincero
that's exactly how he said it too like
uh
like a an inhuman it's vengero it's my
new vincero watch
these are nice swat you want to watch
where people go that guy's a human being
these watches their price point is much
lower
than a watch it would cost you thousands
of dollars these watches cost you a
hundred
and they look really truly kind of like
a million bucks they are a nice watch it
is a nice timepiece there are several
different types of watches
that they offer they have these for the
office or going out to dinner and then
they also have like some waterproof
stuff
it depends on your lifestyle maybe
you're a surfer maybe you're more active
maybe you're not so you can go to this
website
you can check out what they're doing but
these watches are cool people message
ben all the time and they go
what watch are you wearing yeah we
finally have the promo code now i
couldn't give it to you
uh so it's people message me all the
time they go what is that and i go it's
psoriasis
what about this watch and how do they
get it because i'll tell you right now
a watch will make you feel confident if
you're sitting down with a woman you're
having a cocktail or a man
or whatever it's as long as it's not a
child
please i try to give pedophiles
confidence they have enough of it
let's get back to the ad they watch
[Laughter]
it's our first ad for these people right
they're offering you as a listener 20
off your entire order and they're going
to cover all shipping costs if you visit
venturawatches.com you know what this is
this is the christmas gift
for your wife's brother or your wife's
uh
your your sister's husband this is the
christmas gift for the guy you got to
give something to
if you also it's a great gift for
yourself but this is the christmas gift
for
somebody where you want to spend a few
hund's you don't want to go in
you don't want to go into debt putting
together a gift
and you can do a dress watch a sports
watch whatever type of person
they have a watch for them you know yeah
yeah and they have 23 000 five star
reviews on their website you can go read
for yourself that's it
i mean truly everybody loves these
watches they are the perfect price point
it's an insane value for money they're a
great gift you can gift these watches
really to anybody
uh people love them um i think that's
really the direction that you should go
in with a product like this you go hey
let me get a ventura watch
it helps out the tim dylan show i enjoy
that show and um
what's the story of vincero isn't it
inspiring let's see
they don't have a backstory here well i
do you know do you know that i know the
back story oh what is it
it was started by an italian man who was
resisting mussolini
and he and he resisted mussolini for a
very long time
and then you know social pressures are
what they are
he kind of did throw his hat in with
mussolini at the
end but
his but he held out for like a week
his his children
his children uh did not like that and
they were like that is not
most of them some of them were like you
know our father made choices and
you know a few of the children were like
this country should be glorious but
most of them are not fascists is my
point the ones that weren't fascists
carried the vincent what is it vincero
ventera watches to america to start a
new life
and then they became involved in
criminality crime family as many
italians do
and they spent most of their life
extortion racketeering and murdering
people
that couldn't come up with the monthly
vig
now
but the watches were really top-notch
and they're beautiful watchers and then
when the mafia ended
when the mafia ended the vincero family
was just like we're just gonna do
watches
and they then became very obsessed with
obama's birth certificate
and that was an interesting period of
time
um but now they're just selling watches
just watch it and they're nice so how do
we get the ventura watches
i'm gonna have so many calls on my
cell phone keep donating to that keep
giving to the patreon folks because
uh you know this is real go to ventura
watches
they're good watching i mean we're
trying to have fun here but they're
actually good watchers they're good
go to venturawatches.com forward slash
tim don't you dare pay full price at
checkout go to my link and my code tim
will be auto applied at checkout this is
a buy you will not regret and none of
this and we've checked this out none of
this is going to neo-fascist parties in
italy
right now none of it
ventura watch it's a good watch
manscaped is now doing more
than dick trimmers they're also doing
nose hair trimmers hair all over your
body you need manscape
it's great it's the best ball hair
trimmer on the market
shaves your piece makes it look great
also your nose any
orifice that hair is coming out it
absolutely takes care of
manscape has been a partner with this
show for a very long time one of our
earliest sponsors we're
big fans of manscape
i use it ben uses it it's really really
good i make ben shave my dick before
every show with manscaped and then he
goes to a lawyer and the lawyer and the
lawyer's like you don't have to do that
and then i say lawyer you shut the [ __ ]
up
you don't tell him what he has to do he
also has to shave my [ __ ] before
every show
and he used to mind it but he doesn't
mind it anymore right because of
manscape
this doesn't really bother him anymore
and we've got a special offer for the
people get 20
off and free shipping 20 off you just
have to use the code timd
giving away the store 20 off codetimd
manscape.com god they're giving away the
store
manscape.com for your nose and your
balls and everything in between
it's a great way to support the show it
is a really good product
trump dropped out of the digital debate
he dropped out of the second digital
debate people are saying can we also
stop wishing the pr
yeah how many articles do we need here
that are like the president
might experience the worst of this on
day nine
it's like guys how many [ __ ] articles
where you're openly wishing for the
guy's death do we need to see in the
paper
i don't think he's doing a good job i
don't think he should necessarily
be reelected i mean the problem is he's
running against a corpse
so i'm kind of taking myself out of this
one in any type of emotional investment
i don't think there's a huge upside to
either one winning
to be quite honest with you um because
it is just a [ __ ]
disaster but he's out of the digital
debate
and is there one more debate there's
supposed to be a final debate
there's gonna be uh then they're gonna
move the third debate to october 29th
just days before the november third
election yeah so the final debate is
october 29th right before halloween
right before the election democrats are
killing in
early voting they're killing in early
voting
um they clearly have the enthusiasm on
their side
kamala did a good job in that debate uh
with mike pence
pence held his own two he's kind of an
unlikable white guy
you know kamala's got whatever she's got
going on i don't i don't even know her
race i'm not even gonna speculate
she's black and indian and she's
everything and
she just did a good job i don't know
that that changes anybody's mind i don't
know that these debates change anybody's
mind
but we're heading towards
halloween and then halloween this year
is probably not even going to feel like
halloween
because there's lots of places that
won't be doing the trick-or-treating
and then the real halloween will start
on november 3rd
if there is not a clear-cut winner to
this election if this election does not
have a clear-cut winner
we're going to have massive protests
demonstrations
riots and we're going to have a crisis
in confidence
in the government we may be heading
towards a constitutional
crisis if this is not
listen to this right so some my my
manager my old manager
who i had to fire but i love but i had
to fire because he yeah i love him i
would call him and he would just go i
don't know
i don't know and i'm like you gotta at
least make it up
so this is very interesting
there's this article that came out about
epstein called i called everybody in
jeffrey epstein's black book bring it up
but what's funny about the article is
they say you learn a lot about
jazlane uh epstein's connections and
also
stand-up comedy it's odd
read the tagline of this article it's
kind of interesting
and i'm like this is all [ __ ]
stand-up needs we've had enough
in the last few months of people you
know
rightly or wrongly getting a comeuppance
the last thing we need is more [ __ ]
bad press
what is the tagline of this what i
learned about rich people conspiracy
genius just lane stand-up comedy and
evil from 2000 phone calls
well it's like which one of those
doesn't seem like the other
so my ex-manager sent me
a section of the article
epstein took a liking to the comedian
bobby slate who's a legendary
comedian yeah after seeing him perform
at the palm beach improv the guy was a
big fan of mine and his girlfriend just
lane called me for his
50th birthday party she said he was a
big fan and wanted me to come entertain
and that there was going to be some big
high profile people there so i asked
what does it pay
and she says well it doesn't pay
anything but we're going to fly you out
and put you up and i said
what kind of [ __ ] gig is this jeffrey
was a giant comedy i love these
[ __ ] don't pay
they don't pay [ __ ] scum we're just
never respected
we're never respected comedians you know
you could be entertaining the most
successful pedophiles on the planet and
you
still no respect
zlatan mentioned to maxwell off-handedly
that he might bring his wife to which he
answered no women
the party fell through or at least
slayton's invite did but epstein kept in
contact with the comedian
catching his shows around palm beach
miami in new york epstein invited slate
into his mansion in palm beach for
coffee and to
quote talk about comedy but when slayton
arrived
epstein wouldn't let him inside he
showed me the pool in the garage
his cars but he didn't let me in slayton
said he was never invited to the private
island but he once brought it up a
conversation with epstein who responded
that he
didn't invite many people out there when
slayton proposed he and his wife come
out to the island sometime
epstein responded no no wives jeffrey
was a giant comedy fan huge
all he talked to me about was comedy
slayton said he was like a little kid
talking about it he loved guys with an
edge
he loved lewis black sam kinnison bill
hicks
you know what's kind of sad here
i'm not comparing myself to these people
but let's be honest
he would have enjoyed this show he would
have liked it he would have liked the
show
he would have loved this show i think he
would have liked a video where i dressed
up like his temple
i bet and i bet his lane saw that i was
like jeffy would have loved this
they've got a real they've got a real
great dynamic tim and ben
it's sad to know that i am now down a
fan
it's kind of sad it is kind of sad he
liked good comedy jeffrey
he liked good comedy how horrible would
it be if he was like
he hated like he just liked like not
good comedy which i won't mention
what that is but just let it in your
head
jeffrey was a big fan of
that would be horrible but this guy
liked actually good comedy
so why not
yeah but these these articles now about
trump they're a little they're they're
like
doctors said that actually around the
two-week mark is when trump's heart will
explode in his chest and you're like
guys can we stop
you know reveling in the in the
possibility that this
guy might have serious complications
from this
you know trump is not out of the woods
yet they'll they'll be running these
articles if he wins again
they'll be like not out of the woods yet
several months later it's
still a possibility that trump literally
melts
it's never happened before to a corona
patient but it could happen
what about spontaneous combustion where
trump did you ever hear about that used
to fascinate me
people that burst into fire you ever
read about i was reading about this the
other day yeah
because in arizona i i want to see
someone burst into fire
and preferably the entire state i'm kid
don't get mad if you're from marriage
if you're from arizona you understand
everything i'm saying right now and if
you don't there's a [ __ ] problem
it's like i talk a lot of [ __ ] about
long island because it's deserved
it's warranted i've never been like you
know it's a great compassionate place
where people are full of empathy and
intelligence long island
i've never said that i've said good
clams
good bagels good sandwiches i've said
very little about the people
other than that they're funny they are
funny okay
what is this spontaneous combustion is
this real can this happen and should it
happen
yes or yes okay so supposedly there's
about 200 cases of this happening
crazy so like in galway ireland a 76
year old michael faraday
was found burned to death at his home in
december 20th i can't trust anything
from ireland these people are completely
backwards
they have no idea what's going on can we
please find can we go to a norwegian
country or something where these people
have an idea of what the [ __ ] is
happening
ireland believes in banshees and witches
i mean these people don't
michael flatted he died because he burst
into flame
yeah sure he did great thanks how about
you put a floor in your house
but you put floor in the home i remember
us with an irish comedian once
she said why did your grandparents leave
ireland and i went well they weren't
dogs
we're on the way to tape netflix they
weren't dogs they wanted to live in
america because they weren't dogs okay
they didn't want to piss and [ __ ]
themselves
now i love ireland i love the culture i
know that what i'm saying now seems like
i don't but it's
i do but let's also be very honest
there's some issues not the most
motivated crew
it's not the most motivated group of
people living over there in ireland
you know this isn't exactly like uh
let's make it happen
so can we find another example of
spontaneous combustion that's not
centered in the in in in aaron's island
here's one from crown point new york
okay in 1986 the charred body of 58 year
old retired fire
fighter george mott was found in his
apartment all that was left of him was a
leg a shrunken skull and pieces of his
rib cage
what ben how does any of this prove
that he spontaneously burst into flames
like because there were the remnants
weren't there so the only thing that
that people could say was he just
spontaneously combusted and it like they
were just
interesting maybe he lit himself on fire
though some of these they found like oh
he had a heart attack and a lit
cigarette let his body on fire
and then he just burned into flames but
i want to go like that i want to go with
some spontaneous combustion
in a racist restaurant
and i want people to come back and write
about the racist restaurant
and not and not me
so like methane can build up in the
intestines and that might be how it
ignites some people
theorize but no one's ever like
witnessed it themselves no one's ever
seen somebody spontaneously combust
methane meaning like you don't fart and
it just builds up yeah and then it just
something sparks it like you know in a
gas tank and a car dude you look around
i mean
we know me i'm not the picture of health
but i mean you go around the country
i mean is what it is i'm trying to swim
more we had avocados and eggs for the
breakfast this morning
what do you want me to do here you know
um i've made very bad decisions with my
health i've done drugs i've smoked i've
drank i've eaten very bad food very good
food
um but you go around the country and you
look at some people some
people dude i mean it's bad it's truly
bad
the level of you know
decay it's bad
the fat is wild i mean there's a lot of
people that are just way over four
four or five yeah oh yeah big
the skin you see on some people's is not
good
years of environmental factors maybe
maybe it's drugs maybe it's booze but
you look around at people and sometimes
you just look at people
and you feel guilty a little bit because
you have a good life you have a decent
life i have a decent life
it's pretty good and sometimes i look at
somebody at a rest stop they look sunken
in eyes
and i can tell they're they you know
they were probably
raised in a in a coal mine by
two parents that just beat and [ __ ]
them or something and like
this person is just they have these
sunken in eyes
and they're just doing the best they can
um
and like i'm like hey man you have any
yogurts
and they're like you know now
and i feel so bad for them
that i will only i feel like so
bad for them that i will only scream at
them for two or three minutes
like i will not usually i'll scream at
someone for like a solid
six minutes i will genuinely only scream
at these people
for two or three minutes because they've
had it so bad
you know and i go hey what the [ __ ] is
going on here
i mean hills have eyes stills have eyes
out there
i mean this country large swaths of the
country
are full of people who the the horror
move
you could just make a documentary you
could just pull into like any strip mall
and just make a documentary
just put sad music hi my name is fern
like just you got a doc you got a doc
everyone's documentaries are hard no
they're not in this country
they're not at all go to a rest stop you
got a documentary i could make a
brilliant rest stop documentary
tomorrow it's [ __ ] easy
these documentary filmmakers just point
a [ __ ] picture it's uh they point
their camera to [ __ ]
and let them talk for an hour and then
they get a [ __ ]
golden globe and academy award oh it's
so hard to make it that no it's not
it is not just point your go to a
bowling alley
in alabama you have a documentary now
find somebody who's worked there for 30
years
and just ask them about their life you
just hear the bowls
the pins you know and then you have just
somebody
just eating nacho cheese with the one
finger they have left because they lost
the other one to the [ __ ] ball
retrieval
everyone's a brilliant documentary i
mean there's this documentary darwin
which is a good documentary
they just found the smallest town in the
america in death valley california
it's a great document they did a
documentary called october country
beautiful
cinematic gorgeous they just went to a
family upstate that's all [ __ ] up
that's any family hello
you're in a documentary now tell us
about your lives
are you [ __ ] two i'm gonna go win an
award
the guy did it donnell moshe i think
he's a photographer he did it about his
own family
but i will say this i loved october
country
i thought it was brilliant
i think it's called yes i thought it was
brilliant
and then he never did anything else
which upset me and i actually also like
darwin
i just want to let these people know
that artistically i know what you're
doing it's nowhere near
as difficult as what i do every week
which is yell about things that bother
me
with no preparation into a a camera that
i don't even know how to set up
you understand so artistically i just
want you to know that i see you
it's called october country right it is
it's just a tragedy but it's great man
upstate is just tragic it's great and
when you get upstate you just want to
take a pill when you go upstate new york
knowing that down state is just thriving
metropolis or was
thanks de blasio um de blasio's daughter
is like running around shooting cops now
you know
really she was arrested for like looting
de blasio's daughter
his people are i mean god so
knowing that the down state of new york
is like a thriving metropolis
it makes upstate even sadder because
there's some natural beauty upstate
but there are these old factory towns
where all the factories have left i mean
i was just
i got locked out of my chase account and
i just spent an hour on the phone
with people in india and god love them
and listen they're trying to better
their lives
no hatred towards them but all of these
[ __ ] jobs customer service
um you know manufacturing a lot of them
went
overseas with nafta and all those people
in new york state were just left to die
they were just left to to die there and
when you go to these towns you just want
to take a perk-a-doodle-doo
you want to take a a a percocet
my aunt used to get really [ __ ] up on
pills and we came up with a song me and
my cousins
came up with a song where we would just
go perka doodle do
[Music]
perka
doodle won't because she used to just
sit in the chair
uh all peeled out and all drunk now she
just goes on the book
but it goes on the face book
but i'll i'll tell you right now i get
this documentary canard i'm unimpressed
by it
i've been i've been out on the road for
two weeks i've been in nine
documentaries
every store's a documentary things are
not great
magic spoon cereal is a no sugar low
carb keto cereal that fits into any diet
plan it replicates all the sugar cereals
that you had as a kid whether it be
fruity pebbles my favorite flavor they
have fruity
whether it be reese's puffs they have a
peanut butter flavor it's really really
good dan my opener loves
the peanut butter flavor you know
because he's florida trash but still
i think it's very important especially
if you're on any type of diet
to be able to substitute a bowl of
cereal for a meal replacement
or a snack it's very good magic spoon is
some of the healthy yes it costs a
little bit of money because
they're using like monk fruit extract
and really expensive high-end
ingredients to sweeten it
so they don't have to use sugar it
doesn't kick you out of ketosis doesn't
[ __ ] you up
and they also don't use these crazy
sugar alcohols it's really all natural
so it's really important
that if you're making an investment
you're making an investment in your
health i love magic spoon cereal
you know i
i feel like there are people that don't
understand how much magic spoon has
changed my life
you know you know before magic spoon
cereal
i was a cannibal i've never even told
you this i didn't know that
i used to eat people i would eat the
skin
of a person i would cook it and eat it
and it's uncomfortable to discuss this
but and a few of those people i i killed
hookers and
truckers and i would cook them
and i would eat their flesh which was
keto
technically maybe not i think it was
some of them had sugar in their blood
probably
but when i tried magic spoon cereal i i
stopped doing that i stopped murdering
[ __ ]
and eating them and i started eating
magic spoon cereal
and i went to the police and i confessed
and they refused to put me in jail
because they said every they said hey
hey white guy that's what they call me i
said i just killed a bunch of [ __ ] and
ate them they said hey white guy
we all have moments in our life we're
not proud of
they said what made you stop that i said
i'm eating a keto cereal very low in
sugar and i shared it with them
we all ate magic spoon cereal
and uh and they helped me
magic spoon cereal is the official
cereal of the police
so if you support the cops support magic
spoon cereal
a a dollar from every box of magic spoon
cereal
is donated to a derek chauvin's legal
fund
sometimes i do it just so we get the
call
[Laughter]
because sometimes we're bored yeah yeah
what what is the offer here for these
people none of that's true folks of
course
magicspoon.com kept accountable i did
eat people magicspoon.com
tim dillon used to come code tim dillon
for free shipping
magicspoon.com slash tim dillon use the
code tim dillon
for free shipping
it's a great cereal i really love it
they're coming out with new flavors all
the time
it's a great way to stay healthy and
stay fit i'll probably have some of it
when i get back to palm
springs yeah and they'll refund you if
you don't like it
if you don't like it they'll be funny
but you're gonna like it folks stop
hawthorne your skin it sucks everyone
hates you
your breath is bad and you smell like
[ __ ] hawthorne is here to help
why why is it so good you can
personalize your products
that's what the rich do they personalize
things so what hawthorne allows you to
do is you take a little simple quiz
find out what your deal is what you
smell like your pheromones where you
live
environmental factors things like that
the type of climate you're in
and they put together a perfect patented
fragrance for you
and skin creams and everything else it
is a personalized beautiful way
to look beautiful and gorgeous and hot
that's what it is
hawthorne is great they've sent us a
bunch of products we've went through the
process we've enjoyed it
it's fun you create your own little
product you have your own line of things
specifically designed for you
where you live what type of job you're
in the climate you're in
everything it is really truly amazing um
you know mass-produced
mass-marketed clinical stuff has a lot
of drugs and additives in it hawthorne
is all
natural and it's personalized
specifically for you and your
needs benjamin so what type of deal are
they gonna get
so check out hawthorne at hawthorne.co
that's hawthorne with an e
and use my promo code tim to get 10
percent off your first
purchase that's h-a-w-t-h-o-r-n-e
dot c-o and use the code tim to get 10
off your purchase how cool is that
10 off your first purchase hawthorne.co
promo code tim i mean i think america
will bounce back slowly but surely i
mean arizona it's like there isn't
it's a it's not the pandemic in arizona
but there's just every other problem you
could
feasibly imagine go what are the stats
now in new york they got 500 cases in
new york now
we're like 50 000 cases a day in the
country i swear i had this thing in
early march
i don't know that i did but i'm just
gonna say that i did to make myself feel
better
yeah they're turning upward right
they're trending upward right now
because people are going back inside
it's the winter
people are going back inside and this
[ __ ] is gonna trend upward
the kids are going back to school
they're back at colleges
you know you know how it is
tell your kid not to go to college how
about that
tell them that they can't endanger the
family take out a bunch of student loans
and listen to a professor prattle on
about nothing
tell them to go get a goddamn job go
work at a rest stop
you know they have those rest stops
those for real milkshakes
ever seen them they're like these weird
they call them f
apostrophe r e a l milkshakes and you
gotta take which i
don't have any of this but you gotta
take them and then mix them in a machine
and they become a milkshake
i mean this is what yeah this is what
people are drinking
this is what people are drinking in
america a for real milkshake
this is what people are drinking on the
road when they stop into a rest stop
this is what human traffickers are
drinking for real milkshakes
and old donuts with flies on them and
beer and butts and some ciggies
get some trail mix get a few cubes of
cheddar cheese
get back in the car throw some five hour
energy down your throat and get back on
the road to nowhere
and hope and pray that aliens land hope
and pray that aliens land and probe you
right up the ass
because it'll be more fun or interesting
than wherever the hell is at the end of
your journey
mine was arizona
i do respect the arizona woman like the
leathery turquoise jewelry woman i
always have
you know that's an expression that
people have said a lot that kind of
arizona woman and i
i've always kind of respected that kind
of demon from hell
you know like that that just kind of
arizona woman
the people in this state i think pride
themselves like long island they pride
themselves on ignorance
yes they pride themselves you know what
i said there's no [ __ ] schools here
that even you know like everybody starts
clapping
it's cool to be hot here which i get i
get it is cool to be hot but
they pride themselves on a certain type
of ignorance that is uh
you know can be a bit scary when times
are
as trying as they are
a little terrifying the level of
ignorance that some of these people it's
just not bright people
the shows are fun my fans came out
they're they're bright i think my fans
are
a step above they're a cut above
the rest of the people in arizona salt
lake is just desolate
no one's there there's a few mormons
that scurry around here and there
they're clean people the mormons they
don't drink they don't smoke
they run businesses the marriott
families mormon didn't know that
oh really my cousin was excommunicated
my second cousin whatever not second
cousin-in-law whatever my cousin married
this guy
he was excommunicated from the mormon
church at like 17.
they were just like [ __ ] you get out of
here wow
isn't that something yeah they're strict
you cannot get excommunicated from
catholicism really truly although bill
o'reilly tried to have his wife
excommunicated which i still find
hilarious he wanted to damn
the the mother of the children to hell i
forgot about that one of my favorite
things bill o'reilly's ever done
i just think that's such a great
testament to his character it's like not
enough
that that we're not going to be married
it's like i don't want to make your life
hell i want to ruin eternity
as well i want you to burn in hell
forever
how sick is that guy and everybody
watched that guy for like 10 years
and thought that was like a guy that you
could listen to and then he found out
that he was trying to literally get his
wife put in hell
i think you're like you're like oh this
was the guy that was fair and balanced
that was the no spin zone a guy that was
trying to get his wife
eternally damned i mean he went to the
church tried to have his wife eternally
damned because that's what
excommunication is by the way
okay i mean can you imagine this this
guy
he's a traditionalist he just wants his
wife to burn in hell
his kids go dad why where's mom oh she's
in hell
i took care of her he pictures himself
in heaven smoking a cigar
yeah my wife's down there in hell and
his wife just screams
the unending screams of hell if you
believe that horseshit
you know that's what he was trying to do
[Laughter]
i mean if you believe that lake of fire
crap this is what that
guy was trying to get accomplished and
that guy was like the guy that everybody
was like bill's a good traditional man
we should listen to him he thinks we
should go to war in iraq
we're putting up new dates on the uh
website timdylandcomedy.com tim j dillon
a lot of stuff on instagram
uh updating you guys about dates we are
wrapping this tour up can you bring up
the dates ben when do we wrap this baby
up see these ones these these i wrote
down
we got a tampa the 20th to the 21st
tampa is now full
full uh capacity so tickets have opened
up go and grab them side splitters in
tampa
one of my favorite clubs we got palm
beach the 22nd through the 24th
palm beach come down there and bring
just lane
we got oklahoma city october 29th
through the 31st oklahoma city we're
doing halloween me and dan carney will
be there
for halloween gonna be really really fun
we're doing a lot of crazy [ __ ] if you
come out that show for halloween we're
gonna do crazy [ __ ]
costumes stupid stuff it's gonna be
really fun i think i'll be there that
weekend too yeah ben may come out for
that
uh then chicago the october 27th to the
28th
27th through the 28th chicago baby one
of my favorite markets and favorite
cities
now we're in the suburbs we're in the
burbs we're in the schomburg improv
because
the clubs in chicago city were not open
at the capacity that we want
so we're going to the burbs go to
schaumburg take an oobsie
relax you're you people drink and drive
do it kansas city november 10 through
the 11th kansas city i've never been
there to do comedy i've been there for
other reasons when i was a little kid
where i was on an acting
tour with a play we stopped through
there maybe it was the other one
missouri i don't know i don't care
kansas city what is this kansas missouri
kansas city
missouri i believe okay we don't know
i'm not sure the dates are on your
website first of all
who cares the dates are on the [ __ ]
website just buy the tickets
uh then you got denver denver is it
november 12th to the 14th then we are
done
with this leg of the tour then we are
going dark
for december january february now by the
way dark meaning we're doing two
podcasts a week we're doing a ton of
sketches we got a new youtube show
coming out that we're not talking about
there's all kinds of stuff happening
but that you know the podcasts are a
little tougher to do on the road
we still accomplish them we still do
them they're still great but we need to
get
back to base here base camp we need to
so we could create and innovate and do
new [ __ ]
i can't always be in a [ __ ] airbnb uh
you know in arizona
you're the [ __ ] out of here i mean what
are your impressions in this place just
just because i don't want to [ __ ] get
everyone man back me up or don't it's a
skid mark
it really is it is it's a [ __ ] it's a
horror
it's a goddamn horror here
it's like a big pf changs i can't think
of a worse state
i mean it's the worst can't think of a
worse one there's nothing worse
california ain't great but at least it's
got some high points i do like
scottsdale
there's some dope mansions in scottsdale
listen
i there's people in arizona that i dig
and i understand what it is here
but just let's be honest
enough
enough with arizona and enough would
wishing the president death
and enough with ratting out the local
[ __ ] micro
brewery or [ __ ]
gastro pub and i mean i love my friend
my friend joe and his wife
meg in georgia took me out to dinner you
know in atlanta and i was unimpressed
and they have a beautiful home and a
beautiful family and they're not
they're not the the mark of success in
their life is not impressing me and
thank god
they would have failed horribly took me
to some gastropub
folks are we high
we know the rules corporate steakhouse
or nothing
not trying to go to a gas store but this
is actually the best lobster roll
shut the [ __ ] up
i better recognize this place from other
cities
i better know the menu already too much
risk and then we walk around some like
gentrified
area of atlanta i don't want this i went
to big
old homes where i feel like i shouldn't
be
some [ __ ] gentrified area everybody's
drinking cold brew and planning a
friend's giving
burning hell my opener 24 is like this
is so cool
we love girls this time like i get it i
want to see the dark castles
where they control the i want to see
where the power is
not a gastropub stop wasting my time
for the love of god i should have picked
a restaurant i'm never not picking a
restaurant when i go visit somebody yeah
you have kids your job is to raise a
beautiful family and they're doing that
you can't be up on everything you know
they probably went to yelp
probably went to yelp and said which
restaurant isn't racist we want to go
eat some non-racist pokeballs
[Music]
keep buying all the products please on
the show if you need them if you don't
need them buy them anyway and give them
to people for the holidays the holidays
are coming up so important
you know it was good to see my friend
it's good to see old friends good to see
people you haven't seen in a while
you know it really is they're doing
great and i and i and i'm
i'm mo listen i don't need to be
impressed all the time
you know be nice to be impressed some of
the time
just a little bit but i'm impressed with
their family and their life
and that's what they got to do you know
that's what they got to do but
there is something to be said every now
and then for you know
taking out a guest you know the right
way
i paid for the meal take me out
somewhere nice
i said i'll buy a really expensive
dinner please let's go somewhere nice
you know i say go to a gastropub
what are we nuts walk around
what and we went to like a food hall
like a food court
like walking around like are you are you
nuts
i mean truly and i don't think they
listen to this so they won't hear it
okay
you know i'm just saying you guys ate
some [ __ ] up stuff down there right
like waffles and
[ __ ] i forgot what you had we had we
went to one restaurant that was kind of
good and we just had some southern [ __ ]
yeah which i'm kind of over the southern
food of just you know but bacon fried
butter bowls
it's like i just just steak and fish
please steak and fish
and leave me alone yeah i don't need
deep fried cornbread
you know bacon pudding
[ __ ] you know sausage gravy grits and
grease
i don't need that [ __ ] it's not that
good it really isn't that good it tastes
like you should be eating it out of a
trough
it truly does i've eaten in the i've
eaten some of the greatest restaurants
in the world and it's been an honor
for for both me and them and uh
i just find it tremendously insulting
when i'm taken to somewhere that is not
up to my standards
i feel like i it makes me sad
and i hope that um you know i just hope
that
the next place i'm taking is good
you know ben's never taken me anywhere
good
i've never picked a restaurant for you
to go to ever pick because you know
you're not allowed i know and i don't
order when we go out either you're not
allowed to order and you're not allowed
to pick the restaurant and every now and
then
you'll you get you to speak at certain
intervals and you know that like very
much like this show
yes it's not it's not a free-for-all
sometimes we'll sit down and you start
calling and talking and i look at you
like
what's this and then you realize you're
like i'm out of control right now
you're like and then you know the other
thing and i went no no no no no no
down i mean that's that's the game here
that's the game you know i choose the
restaurants i choose the food i choose
the topics of conversation and i talk
about them
you listen you nod you look good you
don't get fat
you look respectable that's that's the
way it works folks
yeah you don't think you think that's
abusive friendship you go find a friend
how about that
that works for us it's actually very
healthy i think it's great we've been
best friends for like three years
this works and it really works you know
he knows every thought out of his head
doesn't need to see that light of day
you know most of them are great some of
them are really good
some of them don't i mean the other one
dan i just kind of hit and stuff i just
push
up against the wall he knows i mean you
can't you can't let these people just
speak and go on and on and on
you got to cut them off out of love out
of love
when they start going you got to go rein
it in and and ben has never chosen to
run i mean he's never allowed
you know ben told me once he goes you
know i really like a restaurant called
rock and egg cafe
and i said you know what i don't go to
restaurants where the first word is
rocking
so you're done now
i like rocking it what did you used to
get at rock and egg cafe
rocking and rolling omelets what the
[ __ ] did you get there i can't remember
like denver omelets and [ __ ] yeah
good and you can do that he's allowed to
do that
i'm just uninvolved i'm to make the
decision
otherwise we end up in a restaurant with
a name like rock and egg
cafe i let dan choose a restaurant it
was [ __ ]
i know what's good
i don't want to know what's good i just
do
if you're the guy that picks the
restaurant always just be that guy
don't let the other people choose
they're wrong
let them do other things like raise
their kids it's very laudable
it's a great activity but you're not
choosing the restaurant because you're
gonna be wrong
and i'm gonna have to make a scene rip
my mask off the coffins in his face
we were supposed to go to the frye bread
house i think we'll skip that yeah i'm
good
i think we'll skip the fry bread house
in arizona even though i'm it is good
the fry bread
is very good by the way i just
my my hatred of arizona is now
unfortunately targeting the fried bread
house which has done nothing to me
and it's just probably pretty damn good
but because it is in phoenix arizona i
am now
launching into a diatribe against it for
no real reason
thank you to everybody who came out to
arizona who came out
i love your state it's an honor to be
here
and i really enjoy the fact you guys
came and spent some time with me
one of the greatest gifts as a comedian
is to travel around the country
and see beautiful and unique places make
connections with people
and things and being here in arizona has
made me
deeply grateful to have the job that i
have and to be able to be on the road
here i love all the club owners that
give me gifts that were in their
children's room an hour
before they gave it to me i love
everyone thank you so much for
allowing me to be in your beautiful
state i do like my job a lot
i don't want to work at a restaurant
stop with sunken and eyes
but if i [ __ ] did and somebody came
in and a fat [ __ ] came in and wanted
yogurt
and i would know where that [ __ ]
yogurt was man
would i know where that yogurt is
because that fat cunt's trying to change
his life
and he's trying to do a high protein
yogurt at 2 am while he's driving
through a [ __ ] military base
on the way to go perform at the fry
bread house
for a bunch of lizards
get tickets to the shows maybe i'll be
nicer to your town probably not
goodbye